[Musique]
les élection présidentielle au suffrage
universel auront fait d'entrée une
victime
l'abstentionnisme c'est en masse que les
électeurs sont venus choisir parmi les
six candidats dont monsieur marcel barbu
celui qui leur semblait le plus aptes à
la magistrature suprême
28 millions quatre cent deux mille
électeurs
monsieur marc si la syrie était inscrit
à jarnac 85 % dont monsieur tixier
vignancour ont voté ce qui représente la
plus forte participation jamais
enregistrée au ministère de l'intérieur
les représentants de la presse ont suivi
minute par minute l'évolution du verdict
populaire
mais ce n'était plus un privilège grâce
à la radio et à la télévision en effet
nombreux sont les établissements qui
s'était mise à l'heure électorale
par voie de conséquence la clientèle des
salles de spectacles avaient
sensiblement baissé ce soir là tous les
moyens audiovisuels avaient été
mobilisés et certains pour en savoir
davantage et plus vite n'avait pas
hésité comme jean-marie proslier à
s'assurer les services du seul taxi
studio de la place de paris
que de monde dans les rues sinon devant
les quotidiens ou l'écoutent et la
vision collective avait été organisée
dans de nombreux foyers dès qu'elle est
partie groupe est au tour des récepteurs
des amis attentif à la géographie
politique des départements et à
l'évolution des pourcentages
et l'heure tardive n'atténue et pas
l'affrontement des courants contraires
ces réunions se renouvelleront sans
doute aucun des six candidats n'ayant
obtenu au premier tour la majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés un second
tour de scrutin sera nécessaire
[Musique]
monsieur jean le camus qui a voté à
rouen est en troisième position avec 16%
des suffrages
monsieur françois mitterrand inscrits
sur les listes électorales de château
chinon est à la seconde place avec 32 %
des voix quant au général de gaulle il
est en tête avec la confiance de 45 %
des votants
[Musique]